it's done it's done you won yep it
wasn't about Cavanaugh at all it wasn't
about the court it was about you the
system that protects you something
called due process but first congrats to
you Democrats this is what happens when
you decide to burn the village in order
to save it and because of that
Republicans finally found their stones
after so much lunacy that we were forced
to stomach by a media who would swallow
anything like the New York Times report
that Cavanaugh once threw an ice cube I
guess the gang rape thing didn't work so
that was your backup what you couldn't
find anyone to blame him for a wet willy
and there was the third accusers claims
imploding all over the place much like
Michael Aven Eddie's presidential
aspirations he did more to harm the
Democratic Party that Bill Clinton's
cigar meanwhile being while the media
ignored holes in the accusers story so
large you could steer Michael Moore
through him
and so after the FBI investigation found
zilch the swing votes went to Cavanaugh
led by Susan Collins a Republican who
went to the Senate floor and
methodically explained why she thought
Cavanaugh was fit for the bench
she smoothly dismantled the anti
Cavanaugh arguments and painted him a
moderate all to convince the libs that
Cavanaugh wasn't a monster but more like
a smurf were they listening were they
listening no the left mocked her because
they prefer their women to think only
one way this way
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so this is a great day Cavanaugh and
Trump and may well have saved the
country by defeating the mob and we are
all vulnerable to the mob
the mob is defined by these things
subversion of justice punishment without
evidence a willingness to discard
individual rights and protections for
immediate political gain a mob is
defined not by diverse voices but by
people imitating one sound the sound of
Rage and that's why it's so scary
the mob is an unbending beast in which
intimidation is its only commodity which
is why it's not about Kavanagh at all
it's about you it's about your kids your
siblings parents spouses because the mob
can happen to you which is why this next
election is huge we must teach the mob a
lesson but if you don't want to listen
to me that just listen to this guy we
need to teach the Democratic Party a
lesson that they will never forget that
you don't f with our system you don't f
with our due process and you don't lynch
somebody based on some sterilization I
love tossing to myself look we're not
savages with torches and pitchforks
anymore we're civilized but everything
awful in this world had to start
somewhere first the election is when you
try to stop it before it gets any worse
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guests
yes she spells doom in the courtroom
attorney Emily campano
he's a comedian radio host and your uber
driver
[Applause]
she's so bright glowworms follow her
home natural review reporter cat Tim
and he can literally reach across the
aisle former WWE Superstar on my massive
side cake Tyrus
so Emily you're a lawyer I'm gonna be
honest with you I actually really didn't
care about this whole process that the
Supreme Court nomination it was
something that I felt was out of my out
of my power it just happens
I didn't care about this story until the
left made me care about it it got me mad
the intimidation in the lies it I think
that's what happened here I think we saw
a process get subverted the process was
100% ignored that was the whole point
and you know I've seen as an attorney
firsthand what happens when the court
accepts as true allegations or
statements that are uncorroborated I've
been a character witness for two
separate false accusation trials and I
saw that the ripple effect can't be
overstated and of course I support the
me to movement professionally and
personally obviously but one does not
equate the other and it's a ridiculous
subversion of justice to to accept those
allegations to me that the that gender
equal lien automatically a truth it does
no one any good whatsoever
you know Tom you don't have to agree
with Cavanaugh's philosophies I don't
think their vote was about that anymore
the vote was a defense of a system as
did the fence of due process and like we
said about the mob I was almost tearing
up Greg really it might be allergies I
have been emotional all week and you
knew you probably mentioned this I don't
know Greg but our great hero Andrew
Breitbart
right he always spoke about what drove
him to become political it was the
Clarence Thomas hearings you write he
would always say that and the anger he
felt with a man being you know that with
due process being thrown out in that
case he he became the right-wing
activist that we all know and yeah yeah
yeah and I think a lot of people in this
country are it's gonna be the same thing
I I feel like there's a lot of people
out there people calling on my radio
show a lot of women Greg a lot of lot of
women calling my show saying I do not
like what's happening here I have I have
brothers I have husbands I have sons you
know so or husband but most of those
calls are wrong number
a lot of people call it into your radio
show because the number is really close
to like fast-food restaurant in that
neighborhood but they all call in they
all call it yeah I think the lesson for
me and you can agree or disagree or I'd
prefer you to agree it's about a tyranny
of the loud and the few who seek to
intimidate the American public that's
the ultimate goal that's how I feel
how do you feel yeah look I think this
was really tough I was watching this and
just thinking to myself I am so glad
that I'm not a senator mm-hmm
cuz like I had the hardest time today
deciding whether I wanted chicken or
beef on my BB Q ball and that is
slightly less consequential than
deciding who should sit on the highest
court in the land right right but I as
you alluded to earlier I think we have
one person to really thank for this and
that is Michael avenatti
yes you're right because when he brought
up all of those incredible insane gang
rape allegations stories it made people
kind of tune out yeah watching dr.
Ford's testimony that was an emotional
thing for me that was I watched that and
I had a tough time deciding who to
believe and I think a lot of people once
they brought out the gang rape stuff
kind of stopped listening to all of it
where they were more willing to believe
Brett Kavanaugh and I oh so I don't know
if the White House has sent him like a
thank-you card
or like or like an edible arrangement
yes no you know a vanity engine excited
more Republicans than Fox News
I thought that was funnier in my head no
pity applause no pity applause here
Tyrus um it's amazing how this travesty
looks now when you look out like two
weeks ago when you're inside of it it
seems so horrible and ugly and now when
you step out of it it seems like did
that really happen
it's weird I did my best not to get in
it
yeah I'm not when it comes to judges and
stuff I tend to just not want to be
around it
yeah don't have great experiences with
judges in general so I tried to avoid
him like a plague but to go back
avenatti I know we're laughing about it
but he concerns me because he was using
fear and just crazy alley to try to ruin
someone's life and move himself ahead
and I think when you there has to be
some type of legal presence for some for
somebody to come out and do what he did
attempted to do what he did and then he
can just regroup and do it again yeah
that's a thing it scares me because like
the American Bar Association is talking
about how concerned they are over
Cavanagh and a vanetti they haven't said
anything that guy should be disbarred
I mean he's using people to advance
himself like even stormy Daniels like
listen she's had a rough life I don't
think if you looked at when history
looks back at this he ever served her
well no she marries she had to pay the
money right send him some Sherri's bear
no it's terrible yes he's gonna have to
pay the money back no one's gonna want
to buy her story and he's gonna hit her
with a fat bill yeah like it's literally
he does not helped anyone he's act maybe
he's a secret agent for the Republican
Party yeah maybe we should look at that
no he did more help for the Republicans
than supply-side economics a strong
argument can be made that
violated a ton of absolutely yeah and he
won't go away